– Hier, guck mal.
Ich hab einen Fotoauftrag von einer
Frauenzeitschrift bekommen.
– Das sieht eher nach ’ner
Männerzeitschrift aus.
– Findest du das zu …?
– Ich find’s gut.
Aber worum geht’s denn?
– Also,
das Thema sind
Frauen- und Männerberufe.
Deshalb hab ich diese Frau in der
typischen Berufsbekleidung
eines Bauarbeiters dargestellt.
– Okay. Also du möchtest Frauen
in typischen Männerberufen fotografieren
oder auch
Männer in typischen Frauenberufen?
– Beides.
Es geht um Gleichberechtigung
und Gehaltsunterschiede
zwischen Männern und Frauen.
Ja.
Und ich überlege die ganze Zeit,
welche Berufe typische Männerberufe sind.
– Na ja, die Handwerkerberufe, oder?
Lackierer,
Maurer, Klempner,
Berufskraftfahrer ...
– LKW-Fahrer hab ich auch
schon auf meiner Liste.
Und bei den typischen
Frauenberufen habe ich:
Friseurin, Erzieherin, Sekretärin
und Verkäuferin.
– Es gibt aber auch viele Friseure.
Ich finde nicht, dass das ’n
typischer Frauenberuf ist.
– Apropos Beruf:
Wie lange willst du denn eigentlich
noch weitermachen?
– Wegen des Babys?
– Mhm.
– Keine Ahnung.
So lange es geht.
Ich glaube, das Problem wird eher
die Zeit nach der Geburt.
– Also, das heißt, du …
du willst das Baby
auf jeden Fall behalten?
– Mitbewohner Nummer fünf!
– Ist das schön!